it's all going to be okay wordsmiths
we're approaching a sanctuary this is a
peaceful video about a peaceful word
[Music]
sanct it's a noun it means a place to
hide and be safe A place of protection
for humans or animals maybe you've heard
of an elephant Sanctuary or a whale
Sanctuary these are protected places for
those animals to live safely I love the
components of this word it's from Latin
and we can break it down into Parts
sanct comes from the Latin Sanctus
meaning holy a sanctuary is literally a
holy place like a room intended for
worship but its meaning has expanded
Beyond just that use an Ary is a piece
of Latin that makes nouns it means a
place for or a person for so a sanctuary
is a a place for Holiness a church
classically where you could hide out
from the law that was
Sanctuary what words can you think of
that contain either of these elements
sanct or Airy I'll give you 10 seconds
of very chill Pleasant music and meet
you back here okay let's
[Music]
go here are three words I thought of
library right a place for books sanctify
to make something holy to bless it I
just took that suffix that makes verbs
iffy I if Y and attached it to sanct
right holy making uh and sanction which
is a kind of official decree it used to
be specifically a church decree but now
it can be used in a variety of ways it
might mean that something is officially
approved like a school sanctioned event
or it might mean a penalty for breaking
a law or a rule like sanctions against a
a company for doing something
illegal let's use sanctuary in a
sentence or two here we can see it as a
literal Ral safe place Jean Baptist
realized that the Shipwreck had become
an artificial wreef a sanctuary for eels
and seahorses the sea creatures live
there they're protected there it's their
habitat but we can also use the word in
a more figurative sense Anam Maria saw
the library as her Sanctuary she could
wall herself up with books and block out
the rest of the world Anna Maria doesn't
live in the library it's a it's a place
where she feels safe she can make a
little book Fortress and in so doing
feel protected I hope that you can find
a sanctuary in the things you love
wordsmiths whether it's books or eels or
shipwrecks I think those are the three
options right you can learn anything
daveid out